joe staley here on the program how are
you Joe I'm doing great
appreciate having me honest and me uh
been looking forward to this be fun
is that right Joe I did not have been
okay I mean man here man big fan of you
thank you I really appreciate that Joe
I'm out now I'm the barzmann sit so high
I just don't know you know how to meet
these expectations yeah we'll see what
this first question is he lives up to
the expectation here we go all right you
ready here's first question Joe's daily
San Francisco 49er offensive tackle
every quarterback is precious Joe every
every quarterback in the National
Football League is precious correct
would you agree with that okay and every
quarterback that you've protected
throughout the years is particularly
precious because he's your quarterback
fine okay
but Jimmy G Jimmy G now this is a
particular piece of China that you must
protect correct Oh
learn to say that this lived up to every
expectation I have a fantastic first
question the setup that the delivery
everything was was spot-on
okay oh right yeah Jimmy Jimmy is a
special guy
you know just been around them just for
the half of the season we had last year
and going to this offseason he's he's
different kind of different kind of guy
he's and we're really excited about him
everything he was able to do last year
with a five game win streak when he came
in and you know the way he's kind of
attacked this offseason and the OTAs and
the minicamp and everything is has been
awesome
yeah but what I also mean though Joe is
speaking on behalf and this is for real
my wife and and many of the ladies
female persuasion this is important
business protect Jimmy Garoppolo yeah I
got to make sure that he keeps those
looks I know that's that's one of the
things all wives all wives across the
country Joe I'm saying just do it for
them you got to protect James Garoppolo
I mean that's a different kind of
pressure you know it's uh yeah now you
got the the whole entire population the
white population out there watching TV
just tuned into
to see his smiling face mm-hmm make sure
the face mask is screwed in tight make
sure it's all look it's it's it's not
just you it's the whole line it's the
equipment manager that all the whole
team Joe know we're on it we know we
know the pressures are under and we're
ready to deliver okay now when you do
say that in in all seriousness when you
say that Garoppolo is a special guy we
did see the winds we saw the the
performance and we've seen it obviously
in New England as well and we've heard
that there is more there are more
players in the NFL interested in coming
to your team because of him have you
noticed that at all in any of the
conversation amongst your your
colleagues yeah for sure I mean in the
in just one of the big ones we had this
offseason was Richard Sherman coming
here and I think Jimmy being the
quarterback of the team was a big reason
why he was able to come here and reason
why he wanted to come here I mean he
spoke that to me in this offseason and
you know a lot of the guys coming in and
just excited about what he can do in the
full season you know we got a glimpse of
you know way what he can do last year
obviously but we're all just really
excited to have the whole entire
offseason to really study the PlayBook
and have a full higher understanding of
what we're trying to do and what trying
to accomplish on offense how every
little piece fits and then go out there
and do it for a full 16 game season so
yeah so what is Richard Sherman brought
to the equation Ivan he's the exactly
I've told him this to his face he's like
the exact opposite of what I thought I
was gonna hate him because I hated him
when he was in Seattle because he was
one of those guys I just kind of got in
your skin but I think that's what makes
him such a great teammate is you know
his ability to to rattle the opponent
you know you're not going to be upset
with a guy that's not doing his job at a
highest level and he's been able to do
that for years and he's come right in
he's taken over that mentorship role
right now for our defensive back room
and we have a really young room besides
him a lot of young guys that are trying
to you know make their way in the NFL
and he's been just like a second coach
out there and
and really taking that role seriously
while you rehabs and you know he's
looking really good he was able to do a
couple uh you know individual drills in
the mini camp that we just had and so
he's been nothing but great
so you Joe Staley are saying you who did
go to Richard Sherman said I was
expecting to hate you but I feel the
exact opposite way now that I've met you
is that what you said I was like I think
I think that was our first conversation
yeah I think he expected me to say
something like that as well because my
reputation I guess precedes me I'm
someone that kind of says what I feel
yeah yeah it was it's been all fun right
now well you know what and I also saw
this kind of went a little viral on
Twitter and your Twitter handle at Jay
Staley 74 you can follow Joe there on
Twitter was yesterday was a response
that Kyle Shanahan gave to a member of
the media asking if if defenses have
figured out the the zone read option
that that is such a staple for his his
read the read zone option for such a
staple of his offense and his response
was just so matter-of-fact where it's
basically like look it depends on the
players and it depends on the scheme and
it depends on the execution and that's
it like no one's gonna stop us if we get
it done right and that's what we're
doing here I'm wondering if you can just
open up a little bit on what the coach
has been like to play for and be in with
Kyle Shanahan and what you could expect
from what we can expect from the offense
this year Joe I've never been around a
play caller like him as far as the X's
and O's and just completely
understanding how every single piece
fits together you know it's not just
with him it's not just he doesn't have
just a mastery of the run game or don't
or the passing game or the screen or the
draw me he has got a complete
understanding of everything and and not
only just like we know what we're trying
to do schematically but like how it fits
and how every single person on the
football field has a job and the play
has to be you
set up in a certain way the way he calls
the play in the game to kind of set up
something in maybe the third fourth
quarter down the road and how the
defense is kind of attacking his he's
like next-level genius stuff that I've
never really been around so as far as
that it's really really exciting as a
player to to be around a guy like that
that you just have a full full
confidence every single time you're on
the field that this is the exact right
play call that we need in this situation
it's just up to us as players go out and
execute it because you never confused
and never ever thinking that maybe I
don't know why he's calling this he's
never that situation with him right now
and then also just in front of the team
he's been unbelievable he's been a great
communicator keeps it very honest keeps
guys accountable you kind of worry not
worry but you know I've questions guys
been a coordinator his whole entire
career and just how he's going to step
into that head coaching role and last
year just seeing how he was with the
team and in front of the team
communicating with the guys and this
happened had been nothing but uh I'm uh
pleased with him as a head coach and
then you Joe Staley again it's you're
entering your 12th season I mean you
have essentially seen it all in San
Francisco Mike Nolan was the coach when
you got there you were there when
Singletary took over and sent sent uh
you know gosh dammit why am I forgetting
his freakin yeah you were sent you you
were there when it's right you were
there from the from when Mike Singletary
Center Ninh Davis to the locker room and
obviously the Harbaugh Kaepernick
Tomsula and then Chip Kelly for first
season I mean what is it like there now
compared to what you have seen before
Joe it's the offseason just the whole
entire vibe of the locker room it's a
very close-knit locker room but the
hotel vibe is just expectations have
been so much higher this offseason which
is which is great but you also got a you
know we felt like we've finished really
well obviously going five and on to
finish the season and we've just kind of
tempered the expectation is a little bit
and not get too caught up and you know
what we finished everything it's a new
season and we have to go into with a
mindset of trying to get better every
single day and watch how we finished
last year but at the same time you can
also build on what we did and getting
confidence from that and I'd say
everybody gets the sense that you know
the expectations and the level plays
expected to be a lot higher this year
and I think we're doing a really good
job of attacking every day and and going
out there and the OTAs and minicamp and
do what we can't improve yeah I know
you mean the expectation level Joe is
off the charts for your team yeah I'm
sure you're aware that right yeah okay
give me is a prediction you want to give
me some form of guarantee what are you
where are you on this front I guarantee
that we will be very prepared every
single week and go out and try your best
now again well look I know you've got a
meeting you got to get to do you have
any questions for me you want to flip it
around you got any questions for me at
all Tom let's see what was your favorite
call of all times
my favorite call yeah we favorite call
of all time when you were on set what
was your favorite tag line oh you mean
my favorite catchphrase
SportsCenter catchphrase well I think
it's got to be you know he got it my
home run call yeah
which was based off the buddy of mine
when I was in grad school trying to get
on SportsCenter trying to start my
career on SportsCenter he's passed out
on the couch while we're watching Wayne
Gretzky try and break I think Gordie
Howe's all-time points record he does it
my buddy's dead asleep wakes up he
stares at the screen he goes he got it
and rolled back over went to sleep and I
swore to him that I would make that one
of my sports in her home run calls if I
ever made it there and so I'm a man of
my word to Joe no I see that you know so
that's that's my favorite call but I'm
available for any other questions any
other follow-up questions Joe you know
I'm around I'm around alright I'll think
of something and then maybe get back
here okay so did this did this meet
expectations are we good is everything
good between us Peter
I think fantastic Joe thanks for the
call take care that will chat down the
line okay all right that's Joe still the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience